george and charlotte
were here and we saw the succession and
it kind of helps calm people but what
did you make of this being georgia's
first big state official event he
handled it like the second in line
didn't he so here is prince george we
all remember when he was born he's nine
princess charlotte is now seven i'm told
that there was a conversation with his
mom and his dad about were they up to it
you know they put it out they asked the
children how do you feel about it they
wanted to participate the decision we
just learned about the decision actually
this morning that they were going to
participate and i think it's just
setting a scene i thought of something
interesting because i've done a couple
of specials on the queen she never
expected to be queen she became second
in line for the throne when she was just
ten she never thought she would actually
be queen she thought her father would
serve out prince george is nine
and he now is second in line for the
throne i think that's an interesting
thing to say never say never right
because listen uh prince william if all
goes according to plan will serve a very
long time on the throne but prince
george is nine queen elizabeth was 10
when she found out that she was in line
for the throne so certainly he's being
prepared
you know just the fact that he's been
subjected to all these formal events and
i think his parents are
starting early to let him know you will
have a very different life they want
them to have his normal life as possible
they've made that very clear that's one
of the reasons why they moved to windsor
and why they're going to go to school
it's it's a little out of the public eye
but his life too was forever changed
prince charles is now king charles
forever change prince william is now the
heir to the throne
life now changed and now prince george
life now changed
[Music]
you